[Music]
no halfway in your cheat table talk to a
little [ __ ] ready for other people
you know there's a regular uh
[Music]
okay let's do a little better than that
wow thank you i feel once and like you
guys care about me
uh good to be
uh we're gonna have a dating show uh
this woman is signing everyone up oh my
god she is just a matchmaker out here
she's trying to get everyone to [ __ ]
uh but we're gonna do a little dating
show uh my name is hans kim i am a uh
i'm just uh you know i'm a comedian
uh i
just killed tony
people well luckily this show is an
exact rip-off of that show so if last
show you will slightly like this one a
little bit less
uh we're gonna watch people date
uh lot a lot of men signed up come on
fellas
here we go
this guy's just gone out of jail
um
we're gonna have a fun time i always
have a guest on this show this week is a
very funny comedian very talented very
uh you know awesome please go for
brittany ledesma a comedian
welcome to the show brittany it's your
third time second time second time
uh i'm asian i should be better at
counting i know i wore this shirt
because what does this say i'm afraid to
get cancelled things come in small
packages
okay i'm just assuming yeah that's a
racist joke that she wore
um but absolutely
yeah yeah you know
it's all about the motion of the ocean
it's not the size of the prize
or whatever
but it's fine you know
i have a small penis um
i promise i want to get high i'm high
uh but the how the show works is that we
pick a name out of the bucket and then
two people go on a date luckily there's
no lgbtqia because that gets a little
complicated but
please sign up if you are it's not like
we hate you it is your month after all
is it is it is
uh and then they go on a date for a
minute and then after the minute you
guys stay right here and then we
interview you and get to know them a
little bit better
are you guys ready to watch other people
date
in front of you
maybe even [ __ ] tonight
okay here we go the dramatic bucket poll
you can still sign up if you would like
so many women tonight i don't know if
these are all real people i pick one yes
we got mike s coming up
isha isha there are stairs right over
there you can go either way it really
highlights your personality what you
choose
feel free to sign up
we got isha and mike s the two people
who signed up the latest going on a date
two procrastinators
going on a date with each other isha and
mike s give it up for a minute of them
dating
hi what what makes you tick
i don't know if you can
speak into the microphone i can't hear
you
hi mike hi
um
if
if you can talk intelligent that makes
me think
that's good yeah
i try to talk smart okay i try to stay
away from dumb things
yeah
what do you do
i'm an engineer by profession
cool currently interning in when was the
last time you dated a white guy in front
of people
this is this is my first time
cool me too
it's been a while since i've been on
one of these dates like never
so what do you do for a living i uh
negotiate contracts i'm a lawyer oh nice
yeah so not not um
i try
corporate law or
like corporate law right right in-house
yeah if you want this to get more boring
we can talk about that some more
okay
do you like to dance
yes
what form of dancing the new created end
time give it up for mike s and isha who
are gonna
be interviewed now
wow
hi mike s
you uh your first question is what makes
you tick yeah i figured that was
open-ended enough to
yeah it's just like your general thesis
give me your mission statement as a
human being what makes you tick
uh
for real intelligence is
we have that in common uh oh what turns
you on yeah i thought that meant what
pisses you off yeah i thought it meant
like what is your motivating factor
well
wow how she answered it was up to her i
really meant like what do you enjoy
that's what i meant by it but she's gone
the other way too maybe we're stupid i
know these that's great did you plan
that one out where are you like this is
going to get the ladies wet plan to sign
up i thought there'd be more people here
i could sit in the backs okay if there
were more people you would have had a
better interview question probably yeah
okay what is an example of a better
question you might ask on a real show on
a real date
a good boring starter is what you do
because then you can figure out what
they actually do and ask them follow-up
questions i always like to start out
boring really get the juices flowing
that way they can have all the
responsibility of
making it fun but you uh you're a very
nice guy i called you a prisoner but
you're actually a lawyer you send people
to prison no
i don't do that type of work but i could
yeah so you do contract negotiation yeah
so
would you sign a prenup or would you
just go balls to the wall i'd sign a
prenup
oh my god what a lawyer how does that
make you feel isha this guy would sign a
prenup it's isn't that kind of like a
cop out
he knows what he's doing so
he respects his professionalism even in
the bedroom
yeah i'm very unprofessional in the
bedroom yeah oh nice he's a professional
in the bedroom what does that look like
you like fart a lot
yeah something like that
okay
how do you guys think of questions to
ask people up here um i generally ask
what i would ask on bumble to the guys
you know like what's your worst quality
is one of my favorite i'm like let's get
all that out of the way yeah definitely
think they will be honest well i don't
want like a see if they answer seriously
then i'm like oh i don't want anything
with this guy but if they're answering
douche like not douchey but jokey like
yeah my worst quality is i can't fully
listen to songs
which is one of mine oh that's rough
yeah i know it's a big flaw of mine
that's right that's the worst i know
hitler often did that yeah i said right
is that why he gave everybody a radio
uh isha what uh what what's like a
dating question that you would ask uh
mike s
okay so
i will try to follow up on my interests
like something i asked him about
do you like to dance
so i'd like to dance so i'll just ask
something about whatever i like does he
also like that or he's going to be
boring or um yeah
i don't think he's doing uh bollywood
dances but
any form of dancing is fine it really
doesn't have to be bollywood what uh
where do you like to go dancing in
austin
i still have to figure that out i'm just
two weeks old here you've just been
standing still in austin so far so far
yeah where did you move from
um so i'm currently pursuing my masters
so came from college station oh that's
awesome yeah
she's taking our jobs
uh so you're how how long have you been
uh in austin two weeks now two weeks
so you're just fresh here
what do you think about it the place
what do you think about the dudes here
like mike s
yeah why are you so good yeah what are
your so far
what is your first impression of my
guess
let's get into it
and gentlemanly i think
yeah he either has cancer or he's like
really into cycling
oh i could see the cycling
neither but
mike you have a wonderful head of hair i
mean your uh peaks your widow's peak is
about to form but what's what's with the
full shave
the full shave i mean
or the uh head the buzz
oh it's starting to go up here so i
figured 30 years from now when it's all
gone people won't wonder what i used to
look like you're set you're preparing
them used to it for 30 years from now
prep for failure he's playing the long
game he doesn't sign uh he he needs a
prenup and shaves his head
he's got all his bases covered
uh do you shave your pubes
for sure that is an important question
i asked the question that uh people are
afraid to ask just to get the ball
rolling
you mean the balls rolling hey
are you a comedian
no but i'm a huge fan of comedy oh okay
well you're doing a great job mike i
usually commend you
so what are you looking for in a woman
are you uh currently out there you know
getting digits
yeah
sure oh nice yeah he's out there he's
out there success rate
uh
to be perfectly honest i i get bored
pretty quick so
not just sport
he hates women oh
no i just uh are you [ __ ] here i'm a
little i'm a little specific i guess
oh he's specific
you're gonna it's gonna pivot to some
race thing or something like that it's a
it's a race thing that's weird
there we knew it well you do look jewish
is that just because you're a lawyer or
the haircut yeah i think you're
projecting though it's the ball nose but
i'm pretty what does that mean i'm
projecting i'm not jewish dude i don't
look jewish at all that's not an
insecurity of mine correct
very fair point uh isha are you jewish
they're clearly not but okay
i mean i know uh indian jewish guy
sampson collector
shout out yeah he's a comedian
anyways
what do you think about uh you know mike
s like do you think that uh
you think
you think he's uh
would you go on a second date with him
you know one minute is too short for the
first date i mean
yeah i'll have to kind of okay just to
get to know him better and uh
uh have you dated a lot in america or
india which where have you dated more
america oh really you're just out here
catching dick
uh what kind of dudes have you mostly
been dating here
um
okay they were
first was like
how many are there jesus went to first
smart dunes
the first round draft picks were
intelligent ones and then from like
different countries yeah but then you're
like let me actually come for once
and
[Music]
you stop dating lawyers
and no i'm just kidding you still have a
chance mike maybe the pretty ones are
but they're dumb
yeah the pretty dumb ones what happened
with the pretty dumb ones
no
no
now what are you what are you what's the
third bowl of porridge that you settled
on as
goldilocks in america
maybe good looks then
it looks yeah
well you're in luck look at mike s his
vacant stairs
are the ending
uh mike s is very handsome um mike what
is like the craziest thing that like a
woman has like uh like a come on like
has any woman ever just come up to you
and been like i just gotta lick your
head real quick
come on
no
uh
i think i don't get approached too much
i think people think i'm out of prison
usually oh weird yeah
i wonder why
actually
you have a very practical uh
facial hair uh style
seems like you're ready to go at a
moment's notice go be in the army you
could
be in a shower in a prison it really
depends
uh mike what's the toughest manliest
thing that you've done
in your life
i was a college athlete
golf
no
soccer soccer
nice
uh it's not qriket but it is pretty
popular in india right soccer
yeah
he's a he's an athlete
i mean
not by american standards but
yeah
for sure
i can dribble those balls the shaved
balls
um so
you guys are a beautiful couple you guys
think you could ever like uh go back to
india and like show him
like tigers and [ __ ]
tiger didn't [ __ ]
that's up to him would you like to come
to india sure yeah i've been meaning to
buy a sitar for some time so oh my god
he's one of those white dudes yeah
do you see a lot of white dudes in india
with backpacks
you'll fit right in
uh yeah so uh yeah what do you any any
uh anything you want to say to mike real
quick just like as a parting word
for the future i love you anyway nice to
meet you too would it be a good sport
start this off
hopefully more dudes sign up
otherwise otherwise i don't know how
your show's going to work
we can just let girls start dating each
other cool yeah it actually boosts the
ratings the show we all want
brittany any any uh word of advice for
this young virgin and couple
um
no
i don't know buy her a drink or
something
okay
would you like to would you like a drink
one that's fine well she she offered you
one through me so it's happening oh yeah
there we go a lawyer buying an engineer
a drink this is the start of a street
joke
well let us know how it goes tag us in
any of your
uh homemade videos later yeah
but thank you for coming on
hope to see you guys soon in the future
maybe you'll have to come back up
because we run out of people
all right but uh thank you guys so much
give it up for mike s and isha
and on a date
we got another group of people a couple
coming up
that's uh isha's name grant
we got giuseppa signing up
grant and sydney
going on a date
what a
wonderful date inside of a date that
she's about to go on
she is with a man she's going to be with
another man now
and he's watching is he a [ __ ]
and grant
one minute of
dating
sydney hi
i'm grant nice to meet you
sydney you just said my name nice to
meet you
sydney uh i have a question for you so
which subject did you like more in high
school was it science or history
who likes either one of them
play along for this one um i'd probably
say
science science okay
what's like a science discovery that you
contemplate when you get high
i don't get high
okay what do you like think of in the
universe like what's a big question that
you're always
pondering if there's aliens that is a
good question what do you think
um
when i when i was in high school no but
now i'm kind of like it possibly there
could be something out there really
multiple earths like multiple parts
multiverse theory okay uh was there
something in the news that like got you
thinking about aliens no what sparked
your curiosity
oh man
marvel
the multiverse aliens marvel yeah i was
gonna go there but so you're a marvel
fan that's awesome
give it up for grant and sydney
brittany was so eager to end this stage
grant said nothing about himself grant
is just asking questions
deflecting
it's being ready to gaslight
he's not being vulnerable at all how did
you feel about his line of questioning
it felt like sort of an interrogation
i'm with her on this one if i was on a
real date i would have excused myself to
the restroom and probably left
oh
grants
this looks like a cult leader talking to
a former member or a future member
yeah he's like hey let's go have sex
with like five other women
you got the hair of a tv televangelist
and the clothes of a uh austin hipster
what what are you what's your deal are
you trying to sell white claws tonight
yeah it's actually what i got in the
fanny pack right here so if you ever
need one so let me know crack one out
seems you uh probably need a drink right
now actually oh my god what the [ __ ] was
that dude
how is that how you answer questions dad
cindy uh what do you think about grant
and his beautiful lock of hairs
way better than [ __ ] oh yeah whatever
that guy was you know him at first
douche
oh
douche
you mean he cleans out vaginas or
probably
dries them up real quick
um
sydney i mean you're here with a date
you're on a date uh did that inform your
decision
at all so i've learned that my type is
my type i don't like people who talk a
bunch because then it's like so you're
like be quiet and chill and we have good
child guys who have probably killed me
get a word in
yeah unlike you uh
but yeah this this guy seems like a nice
guy you know he seems like he could kill
someone how long have you been seeing
this guy
how long
year and a half year and a half
wow
this would be pretty hard you guys are a
pandemic couple basically
who who gave
covet first
i drew him koben oh [ __ ] i work at a
hospital he's still with you oh you're
uh you're a hero
i'm a sleep technologist i watch people
sleep for a living
that's the most dangerous time to get
coated
um but thank you for your service
grant hasn't done anything besides
drink mimosas on uh outdoor patio in
east austin
he's still a hero
you are our hero grant
grant uh what did you do today anything
fun yeah i just got back from the pool
with my friends just had a few drinks
got a sunburn
whoa he lives on that gun's out
he's having a good time
grant knows how to have fun
uh what's the craziest thing you've done
this summer
hmm craziest thing i did this summer
now i'm trying not to give a douchey
answer it's a lot of pressure uh
she already has a boyfriend
yeah nothing can go wrong here okay the
craziest thing i did this summer
was uh probably
um jump off of a cliff
oh dude do a backflip that's [ __ ] rad
bro
yeah i do a backflip
did you drink a red bull on the way down
no bang energy for sure
i look like a bang rep
more than a red bull rap probably okay
yeah no i i was chugging some beers
water was cold i had my dog chased me
out oh is that when i was there at the
green belt yeah not really a cliff
it was at most five feet
it was really cold water cold i didn't
do anything
well coolest thing you've done this
summer
literally the coolest
oh my god this guy doesn't get laid
that's the coolest thing you did to jump
five feet off the ground
i'm really scared of heights
truly you're like as tall as the cliff
i don't like to look down period
yeah sad down there you know little
packages and all
now grant is a very uh very big man um
so uh if you don't like to look down do
you need a taller woman that's what i
was about to ask so you probably get
laid very often i do like tall women you
need like six foot and a boat yeah i do
like to date uh taller women my last
girlfriend was six foot
but i've always been open to dating
women of other heights too i don't
discriminate too much
what a nice guy
oh my god you're so charitable
so you like someone who like can take
you in a fight
i kind of do respect like a powerful
woman that
yeah i [ __ ] around too much she'd put
me in my place you know
uh ladies he likes to get tied up if
anyone's into that okay that just being
tied up in bed i get it you want to be
lazy today
yeah yeah
you want to give up and that was just
like that
that's the worst i hate
i hate people like that grant we all
hate you for your laziness in bed uh
cindy what's the craziest place where is
the craziest place you and your
boyfriend have
boinked
god
um
you guys [ __ ] here
oh yeah
okay we're up here right here
have that effect on a lot of people
um that's cool so uh you guys are like
vanilla vanilla yeah you're white
um
is your boyfriend white he looks kind of
mexican
no he's white
oh you seem pretty sure about that did
you
is that important to you
i think he just has a tan hans yeah
look at gray he doesn't have a tan
this turns red yeah um grant what uh
what do you think about uh this
situation i mean you're here with a girl
and her boyfriend's right there like i
think i'm making him look really good
right now so i'm doing a good job what a
good wingman
bring grant out to your dates he will
embarrass himself yeah i like to hype
people up
make sure he's uh taking care of you
good for you you're not a douche anymore
thank you you're welcome i know i have
resting douche face it's not the first
time i've heard about stuff
you look like one of the characters and
the lion the witch in the wardrobe grew
up
which one the one of the kids
one of the douchey ones
so the older one that gets the sword
that kid
grant are you that's not that's
certainly
for like a hot guy
he isn't getting i heard this rumor that
grant used to be kind of like he did he
doesn't have this he uh he used to be
ugly and fat
yes it's it's very true if you go back
like just a year or two on instagram
you're like who the [ __ ] like ate that
guy
that's the true guy yeah we're ugly and
fat
well i was fat i'm still a little ugly i
can't really change my yeah too much oh
grant don't say that about yourself oh
thanks no don't say that about yourself
please that's for us to say
that was gonna be my next line
uh but no you're uh not that ugly
uh but yeah he's fishing for compliments
that's cool so does that why you started
studying you're like maybe if i know
about the lion the witch and the
wardrobe someone will touch me yeah my
i wanted to have a strong powerful woman
like the witch to uh
go after to tie you up exactly in her
castle with all those turkish delights
i still want to know what those taste
like honestly
okay grant telling us a lot about
himself just now
cindy do you have like a favorite piece
of fiction like are you a fan of uh you
know sabrina or sisterhood of the
traveling pants
so inflatable to women wow
mama mia while you're at it
my mom that adds up no the dread told me
you uh you enjoy any tv shows or what's
your favorite thing criminal minds stuff
like that oh [ __ ] she's a basic white
woman we love true crime ethereal
killers so if grant were to murder
someone how do you think he would do it
be hot sadly and how do you think you
would catch him doing it
oh man he'd probably like
kidnaps like
six foot old women and like puts him in
the trunk of his car wait what's grant's
first and last name
grant thornburn grant thornberg probably
probably kills six foot
older whitman stuffs him in the back of
the truck and then his tail lights out
and they find the body yeah she just
makes you look like an idiot dude well
let me stop you there there's no way she
would fit in the trunk of the car if she
were this tall let me poke some holes
into how this would not work so it
drives a fiat
the clown car yeah he rides from the
back seat
with five of their tall people
exactly grant uh have you ever been to a
bachelor party absolutely yes
yeah bro yeah what did you do there uh
we went to lake tahoe a bunch of us and
got a house by the lake we smoked a
bunch of weed
that's illegal dude
dude believe it or not in that area it's
actually legal i bought it at a store
and uh
yeah grant doesn't do anything illegal
he does not smoke weed the only weed he
smokes is uh delta eight yes that's how
white he is delta eight brought to you
by the creek in the cave yeah i'll have
uh anything that's legal and enjoy it to
its full extent like this lone star
right now
so you smoked weed on a lake
is that anything
we got
off a cliff
we actually went looking for bears which
was probably the most dangerous thing
i've done in a while is get high and
think you can fight a bear there was
multiple of us i was like a gay dude or
an actual bear oh my god
we don't know uh it was probably more
likely gonna be a gay dude in the forest
over there we did not find any bears
probably a good thing too damn
this guy's gay as [ __ ]
adds up
i mean that's sort of weird
yeah
he's he's just out there looking for
bears
it's just
he's up to no good this guy yeah that's
how i got in here i was looking for that
guy right there oh you found it i want
to sit him right here
anything you want to say to the bear
right now
hey king
how you doing
what is the flag around your uh your
neck what is that is that crying doesn't
talk back so it's uh sydney
what do you think
you uh you're gonna you're you know when
you guys marry he's gonna have a
bachelor party is grant invited
to your bachelor party he he'll smoke
weed
i will
i mean
if he's gonna smoke weed and go look for
bears i mean i guess that's okay i know
it's gonna be a wild time you guys are
not gonna remember if there was a bear
or not
so i
yeah that's that's fine sure we're not
okay helen is coming he's coming to the
bachelor party
grant lives for bachelor parties i do
i'll make sure it's a good time i'll get
him really drunk and then when elise
suspects it i'll take him into the woods
and we'll go kill that bear together
well that's not where i could
take advantage of him
is this what white people do they just
i'm gonna go kill a bear yeah it's in
our dna that's more like a russian thing
to do
yeah i don't know where i was going with
that
um but you guys are both white uh what
do you think about
the uh you know
so what's going on in the white world
you know
aliens apparently bailey marvel movies
oh top gun
love it you're a black panther
two very different movies i think
i didn't see top gun so no wait did your
boyfriend see top gun
oh he's just dying to
he's sick of watching traveling
sisterhood pants or whatever
he wants to watch tom cruise murder
russians
um but grant
huh i said hell yeah oh [ __ ]
britney uh her dad is a fracker so she's
american as [ __ ]
i'm mexican
you're a chola right
gender
i apologize to the mexican-american
community
i didn't realize
that you were mexican
um
but anyways you know a lot of great
stuff in mexico you guys ever been to uh
rositas it's a pretty good time
isn't that like a drive-through yeah so
a lot of great places have
drive-throughs
uh but anyways you guys uh anything
what's the most racist thing that you
guys have done this week
damn there's so many to go through um
today i went to a juneteenth party and i
was white so i guess that's kind of
racist right boo
we hate you grant
that's illegal
uh no thank you for supporting you know
you're an ally
uh
thank you i'll drink to that
he's supporting the cause you know
you're gonna you're gonna go protest
next time yeah i'll be there you count
on it yeah put a sign up because it'll
it'll go far farther than most people
yeah put it way higher up it's like a
reflection
collective dude under there
uh sydney uh what's the most racist
thing that you've done this week
my gosh
um
i don't
know
i honked at a black lady who was driving
too slow on juneteenth of all dates
haven't they been through enough
i don't know if i can continue this date
i'm going to cancel you right here now
did you know she was black
did you know she was black when you
honked
no i didn't but then
and then it was like i kept we kept
passing each other to flip each other
off it was that's kind of a moment
that's a beautiful moment of racial
harmony right then
you know we just flip each other off
mostly but now we're flipping each other
off and no one dies
anyways uh thank you for sharing that
that was very vulnerable and very cool
that you shared that with us you know
you're allowed to honk at black people
they're equal now no i've got
i take that back i apologize to the
black community as well
uh but that was the date uh it was
sydney and grant going on a date with
each other so give it up for them
and let's hope that
grant doesn't get beat up
he looks like he has connections to the
mob
are you italian
okay
that's good
we got a lot of men signed up now so
should be good should be a lot of
people that can
physically [ __ ] each other
uh akhil
coming up
akhil akhil
dolce mack
going on a date with dulce mac
comedian
extraordinaire
uh dulcinea matt going on a date with
achille
here he is
the beautiful achille
genuinely i was going to sit at the pack
and enjoy my beer but isha shined me
okay making excuses right out of the
gate
achill and dulce going on a date give it
up for them one more time
hey hello i'm a kill
dulce i heard you are just a comedian
yeah i don't know why he said that okay
yeah
then your expectations are too high so
let's bring them down like right here
you got you get nice tattoos there oh
thank you
it's beautiful thank you
when you eat pizza do you eat the crust
so
i know a girl who likes the crust so i
just eat the pizza and give the crust to
her
who is the girl i mean we're talking
about us
sorry girl but whatever all right
all right yeah so do you like the crust
i do i won the whole pizza um when you
pour cereal do you pour the milk first
or cereal first everybody knows that
what's that
cereal
you put the cereal first yes okay that's
did you put play milk first no
okay then we can talk okay end time give
it up for atkill and dulce
wow
achill it seems like this is your first
time talking to a girl you're like
actually listening and responding
you care about crusts all of a sudden
crazy yeah that's cute
alone bro echo what was that girl you
were talking about was that your mom
yeah who is the girl
yeah you live with your mom and do you
feed her crust dude there's there's this
girl who likes crust and i used to
search her where is this crusty [ __ ]
are you talking about isha
she over there eating a crust right now
no
i want my friend
in my school
yeah okay your uh girlfriend
no you just have a bit of a woman that
you just peed
did you like her though because saving
the crust for a girl is something you do
for someone you like not just any girl
we had
did you want to be more than friends
with benefits
he's indian so that means he came with
none
that's the benefit
okay
so you guys are
boinking around at the classroom shoving
crust in each other's mouths
having a good time yeah
that was some good time yeah
and i now you just bring her up on dates
is she living with you in austin no
she's back in nc
nc yeah a rally that's my i'm from nc
state so she's back there
north carolina
is one tree hill a real place i'm sorry
his tree held
it's i guess our minute is over please
oh it's he doesn't want to talk to me
anymore
um
no
not a bad boy didn't think so
are you a good dancer
dude
maybe yeah could you show us a little
bit of uh your dancing right now if we
could get some music oh [ __ ]
achilles
just warming up for it right now you're
just taking the camera
no it wasn't for you okay but the minute
is over
call back
she doesn't want to talk to you dude
you're going to have to dance for her
this is the only way to her heart
what type of dance do you like tap
hip hop
river dance break breakdown what kind of
dance can you do
whatever she asks break dance
okay go ahead and break dance for us
achill youtube
let's get some music
you might have to move the chair
he's putting his glasses down he's about
to head shake
oh i don't trust you that kill is still
learning the rules of this
show all right here we go some good
techno beats there you go
wow look at him
move his hips
wow
dulce can you break dance back i don't
want to break dance i want something
more i'm sorry
okay what do you want sir
sometimes i would love
what does that mean what are we what do
you want to do oh did he say a dance of
the lamp yeah
no no
i said lap dance of love
dance
yeah
okay romantic dance okay i'll show you
this you can't have sex say jackpot it's
like the dance of love is he trying to
[ __ ] i know jesus actually yeah this
isn't north carolina
but around here we don't [ __ ] on stages
yeah no all right
i'll do a dance of love
a love dance from dulce mac give it up
for dulce
and she left the stage
you need to go chase her now this is
like a bollywood movie
you guys got to do peek-a-boo from
behind the curtain love doesn't exist it
leaves that's
oh
you guys gonna have a problem
you guys haven't even started dating for
um five ten minutes yeah and you've
already broken up uh yeah i know it's
over i'm going to the pizza cross school
achill you're a very good dancer you're
very expressive you got a sense of humor
you're like moving your
hips around and like
shoving mobility shoving your head with
your hand and it's very thematic
uh
yeah i mean
you're uh i think we could see your
boner because like your pants are like
so sheer
but
do you uh do you go dancing a lot or is
that something that you like to do
um
yeah
try to dance a lot when i'm super drunk
yeah yeah do you like to get super drunk
yes
alcoholism
dulce loves alcoholics
i do
it's true
for an alcoholic you respect women a lot
yeah
you're beautiful
the minute is over
turn it off
for once jesus
echo what's your dating history like
so
i just
like last week i guess last saturday i
went out with the girl
okay bob she was a mexican
she was indian a mexican
and what was she
she was in the pub
she was in the what what did he ask
you thought she was mexican no she was a
mexican okay so you thought correctly
you went on a date with a mexican yeah
and i met her in the pub
at the bop at the pub
club yeah
i was like is that a cool place
so you had a couple brews with her yeah
that's it
and then you started dating history but
yeah one day
one day with a mexican yes that's your
history you want me my history i had a
breakup
like
when i was in an undergrad so
like around
it's like
three years back yeah okay
so later right and then you didn't date
anyone no and then you're like let me go
find a mexican
do you like latinos yeah
i mean yeah
that is the most racist thing that's
been said on this stage mexican but i am
offended right now
i didn't mean like
um
you meant nan i want to give her nan
uh so i didn't like that girl so you
didn't like that mexican
that's why i wanted to mean should have
flipped her off like sydney does to
people she hates
dude she has a tesla
she had a tesla
that that gets you hard right i can see
you're getting heart rate yeah
okay dude
what do you think about this guy he went
on a date
that he decided is his dating history
and like there's like a tesla involved
like
you never said what was wrong with her
so i don't know
you just said she's mexican and then
nothing else
so i think
he
is full of himself i think he probably
has raspberry sparkling waters in his
fridge he doesn't even drink them he's
like girls like these
and you're fake as [ __ ] yeah
you're just trying to you're a [ __ ] boy
aren't you
yes a nice fuckboy the evilest ones
achill i think dulce is gonna
you know go home with you tonight
you should keep playing your cards right
i will be gone in like 10 minutes
yeah don't make her dance again she
hates she always leaves
yeah i will leave at dances i will not
rap
stop trying to make me
can someone drop a beat for dulce to rap
after that hill's gonna rap back to you
oh that's cute
yeah it's a rap battle
okay
dude all right let's do it no no energy
girl and be like i just met the craziest
[ __ ]
on stage she hates i miss you
i got all these crusts in my closet i've
been saving up for you
what uh what's this crust girl's name
um
yeah
nice sounds like uh like a german
warrior
herschel hirshtag
hershtag uh eats crusts and you eat the
actual pizza did you ever like let her
eat the pizza
yeah i yeah oh what a gentleman
you get the pizza and the crust okay wow
the whole package
yeah i even gave her breadsticks
anyways
dulce um
so what do you think about achille and
his
uh crust
answer
i think uh that you guys will be
together later in life because you
brought her up on a date dude you're
never going to get laid like this every
time you look at pizza you think of her
so
you will think of her a lot
and you text her later
and you guys will meet up and have
babies or whatever
this is a
pizza
tasting a pizza love story
okay a hill uh anything that you'd like
to say to dulce just to uh you know let
her know that you know like
you know you still got it you're over
hashtag
don't leave in 10 minutes
oh
on that flight
he's been watching friends don't know
what to say
she's speechless
he's about to start dancing and run away
yeah
i'm gonna do a couple of spins and get
out of here
wait can i ask him a favor that comes
from brittany
you're gonna ask him to take a picture
picture of us
that is such a waste of time
it's gonna no one's gonna say anything
it's going to take forever
nothing's going to be accomplished
all right
give it up for her
and dulce
they took a picture they could have
taken after the show during the show
at least get the audience involved if
you're gonna
what a perfect couple couple of nerds
that follow instructions
trying to [ __ ] each other in missionary
style
but we're gonna see another date we got
two more men left
and then the women are gonna have to
start scissoring
oh three men
okay we got amanda coming up
and jay
amanda and jay
can't wait to meet this lovely couple
amanda and jay
sure
hello amanda and jay one minute starts
now
thank you yeah
and lemons on your shirt
yeah cool do you like lemons um yes i
actually do love lemons
uh i i have not made lemonade how about
yourself
uh generally
squeeze them over things
um
you know just like whatever i'm eating
at that particular time yeah i mean i do
get some lemon drizzle kind of like
stuck in the beard as well
no that's cool
yeah are you are you are you into that
like
yeah probably
yeah
yeah a little higher
i need to get high people are smoking
and there's like really
really i might be too honestly yeah
yeah hell yeah
cheers
end time get up earth amanda
and jay
going on a date you uh
said you squirt you squeeze lemons
yeah he squirts you squirt
you're a squirter that squeezes lemons
yes uh
did you ever think about trying to make
that sexual
the the lemons sweet the squeezing or
the squirting the squeezing and the
squirting i never thought about it like
in a sexual context
before but i think it might be cool
because it kind of burns a little bit
so
yeah i could see that working for
something well you squeeze it over
things that you eat maybe you could
squeeze it on some [ __ ]
that's painful
oh yeah
yeah this is so fun
yeah it's uh
the ph balance it's like you have to go
to the er after that
you're like why are you here i had some
guys squirt some lemon on me
he had to season me before he ate it up
balance out the ph
it is a bit acidic
um
what uh what's the craziest thing you
squirted a lemon over
oh man um
uh
you know nothing too crazy maybe like
scrambled eggs
yeah that's gross
likes eggs
oh yeah i i
you love squeezing your juice all over
eggs
way to make that sound ah
jay uh
uh you have a big beard amanda mentioned
your big beard thank you right away does
that uh ever get you laid with any of
these like gothic chicks or something
um like beards like not really it's more
like young more like young
men that are really into beards i feel
like oh nice yeah you're the bear that
uh grant was looking for
so uh what are you doing nowadays you uh
you grooming that thing you're trimming
it up you go to a barber you do it
yourself
yeah it's like a once a week trim you
know like i just like shave the head and
then i trim the beard so it's all like
streamlined once a week
yeah that's what uh he was trying to
look like this is you before you grew
your beard out
so yeah actually yeah pretty similar
beard structure
how long have you had it
um
probably january 6th [ __ ] writer
probably about yeah sorry about ten
years ago that's commitment yeah ever
since the q anon shaman went into jail
he's like now is my chance
uh what do you think about uh you know
the uh are you vaccinated
weird yeah
he's vaccinated yeah um amanda are you
vaccinated
nice you guys both voted for hillary
clinton
you guys can bike together in the bike
lane
what uh what do you like to do in austin
yep
i don't know
you don't know
i mean just kind of i just kind of
wander around
jumping
wander around
it's kind of dangerous around here
do you take bird scooters ever or do you
have um
you have a bigger scooters
stuff up when i was like in second grade
on a scooter oh dates back to the razor
days yeah those ones those crazy ones
yeah we're trying to do a flip
we were going open half pipe
it started wobbling i was going too fast
i just jumped into a pile of gravel damn
yeah that would seem oh look a nice soft
pile of gravel that'll break my fall oh
we skid to a stop with my skin
uh no that's pretty traumatic i mean
they're not the safest things you know
it's uh
a lot of people hate scooters
uh a lot of people came here on a
scooter it looks like uh but what uh how
do you get around mostly car
ooh
jay does that jay do you drive
yes what color is your van
uh
it's
it's the uh green convertible astro van
outside scooby-doo
am i scooby-doo
yeah you look like scooby-doo dude okay
i think i know you're the van yeah he's
shaggy after he did two tours in vietnam
yeah
do you uh i i mentioned before when
you're on the show you don't blink a lot
right i've been working i've been
working on that like since
yeah
is it like is it obvious that it's like
a fake blink yeah
[ __ ]
um you said you like lemons and you have
lemons on your shirt do you have any
other clothing that has other foods you
like on it
oh man you know i don't
oh my god what are you thinking about
right now
just like i was thinking about
how i might want like to acquire like
like an eggplant shirt or just some like
more food type shirts or something
that could be it's a good investment
yeah you'll be the fruit guy
you could be like oh this guy's
from hawaii or he's a douchebag
well he has tevas do you like outside
things
yeah i i just started lifeguarding at
barton spring so i'm outside like every
day now
doing oh [ __ ] yeah you're protecting
people
i guess i mean haven't really
saved that many people so what's like
what's like the number one thing you
have to do you have to like tell people
to stop running
yes yeah what about to stop eating
stop eating yeah yeah yeah i have to go
i can force those rules do you use your
beard as a life-saving device
grab my beard i'm going to swim to shore
a pencil rapunzel
long beard yeah you guys could go
together you got uh
beautiful long hair
what uh what do you think about
what do you think about his beard i mean
you could braid his beard he could braid
your hair
you guys could like swap
no
okay i don't know how
how sex works
i think sex works the same if you have a
beard or not
well i think i mean into the beard until
he talked about squirting lemon juice on
it
damn
you try to tie it together you're like
she mentioned beards let me squirt some
lemon on my beard and make about the
beard again
do you get food in your beard often
yeah i really like uh there's this nut
butter called nutso
it's like seven different nuts and seeds
and
um
i'm like addicted to this currently
and uh i eat it every day it's really
oily so i always get nutso like on my
beard got nuts on your beard
oh
yes
you're just
you're just making this easy
uh so you uh you eat a lot of nut bars
that come with your lifeguarding job at
zulker
i i just take the jar and then i eat it
with a spoon out of the jar
yeah
oh my god how long have you been in
austin have you ever thought about you
know going somewhere else you know
collecting yourself
do you believe
it's just concerning he's just eating
nuts
out of a can is this an austin thing
well pro to him at least he's not
allergic to peanuts
well yeah you're not a snowflake are you
i actually i actually am allergic to
peanuts god damn it i actually peanuts
peanuts is the one nut that's not in
nuts so it's like every nut but peanuts
so you're allergic to peanuts just very
very like it just basically gives me
uh acne it's not like anything bad
happens but
yeah just just like
zits
that's a creepy way to stand on the top
of your head
um you know
most of them happen like on my neck it's
this weird like the only place i seem to
get the sits it's like redneck more like
acne neck
this guy's a nerd that
lifeguards at silker
lemons help get rid of i mean barton
springs right yeah lifeguard is soaker
it's not a chill
um
oh i said does the lemon juice help get
rid of the suits i haven't tried that
actually that might yeah there's like
pointing it all over the place yeah
amanda what's your dating history been
like in austin
zero zero dating i mean i went on one
date and
then was it with a mexican
no did he think you were a mexican do
you have a tesla
okay
and uh so you went on one date in austin
and then what happened
thank you for the date
you're like i'm one for one i'm going
home right now
cashing in my chips
well
if you love autism
you'll love austin
uh there's a lot of tech bros here
uh
a lot of people with jeeps
that's cool
what kind of cars do you like your guys
to drive
even no car
i mean
it would be cool if they had some sort
of way of getting around that would be
cool
okay that's good to
know taking notes uh jay uh what uh
what's the craziest date you've been on
um
maybe this one
okay is there one you could tell a story
about um
oh yeah one time uh
went to graffiti park back when that was
here
um
graffiti park was this like
just big graffitied place
and so descriptive
can we drag the story out a little bit
longer okay i'll abbreviate it we [ __ ]
actually
yeah
well that's why they shut it down yeah i
uh yeah it was right after that yeah i
[ __ ] it up for all of us
you got lemon juice all over the
graffiti
spilled the nut butter everywhere
you learned to clean up after yourself
sir
uh but yeah i mean i hope you had a
great date uh amanda what do you what do
you think about uh this fine specimen
i think he's an interesting guy but uh i
don't think i would date you i'm sorry
that sounds like a challenge jay that's
what she wants
that's not nut butter
i'm not offended if you don't want to
date me it's okay
um well wait was i supposed to say as
well well just you know
like talk like a normal person say
whatever you want to say
oh um
no i i get it no no hard feelings yeah
that's it i get it he has to live with
himself yeah i get it
um
well jay you know
amanda's only been on one date in austin
you're her second
you know
you did it you're 50
thank you you're 50 of her dating life
right now
yeah i'm gonna keep i'm gonna keep
chugging i'm gonna keep going you're
gonna do great jay yeah i got this you
know get some visine blink blink blink
sometimes
but uh you're doing great and it was
great to see you go on a date give it up
for amanda and jay
let's get another name up here
so many guys and girls let's just go
right through them
we got
elodie
elodie
elodie coming up elodie
and kia
and kya that's the car that amanda
drives
she is asian she loves music
melody like melody bad joke start now
one minute of dating and go hey what's
up uh not much nice to meet you all
right i want to save some time what are
your biggest red flags
like in a woman
or the or the red flags that i have
let's do both okay the red flags that i
have
i have a very small number of friends
um okay
for a woman i would say
this is gonna sound really judgmental
if i ask you like what was the last book
you read and you don't have an answer
i see
okay what about you what red flags hmm
okay so like
i i don't know like i have like oddly
specific ones like so actually the last
book i read was a graphology textbook
and apparently there's a thing called
forensic graphology where you can tell
who did a crime based on their
handwriting and ever since i was little
if i didn't like a guy's handwriting
that's a deal breaker for me okay
that's good no what what what is a deal
breaker that like you
give off or sorry a red flag that you
give off
where do i start
and time give it up for elodie and yeah
let's let her answer the question
let's hear the answer about like what
red flags i guess
yeah okay i don't
i don't like do you mean like evidently
because i feel like maybe the biggest
red flag is i'm probably like good at
hiding them like
oh oh sam
she's a psychopath
uh ella d and kia what a wonderful date
i feel like i'm at a dog park in east
austin right now
uh very hip
two cool hip
hip people what do you guys do around
here you like code you guys coding i do
actually oh
the uh
i'm also a computer science student now
sorry you guys have ethernet ports you
can plug together
we'll talk and we'll compare foreign
your name is kia
yeah
does that uh
well how does that you know you ever go
to kia dealership just because you felt
like you had to
um
no so i've heard they're actually really
terrible cars
okay i'm korean so go on i'm sorry
they might not be that's just what
people say like um uh and a lot of
people
it's three letters and somehow a lot of
people mispronounce it like i get kai a
lot so i always have to say like it's
like the car but then everybody's like
oh they're bad cars
oh okay
insulting yeah
it's been spending a lot of time on
youtube comment threads
um but yeah you uh you meet a lot of
people who hate kia's as cars like how
did you get to be named kia
my parents did not conceive me in one
that's a common question
they birthed you in one yeah
um no actually so
uh kia my dad is iranian and kia means
crown in
brown yeah crown okay
and then the shah was recently
deposed of and you're like oh it was
like the 50s it wasn't that recent okay
so you're not 70 years old you're saying
um so you you're named after the crown
and uh what's your mom is your mom
iranian no she's a
white lady she's a basic [ __ ]
kinda yeah
she does love true crime okay is she a
wino
no they're both beer people oh i'm from
the midwest so it's like a very beer
thing
that's disappointing
beard or beer
because beer
beer onions have long beards
no my dad's more of a mustache guy no
beard nice yeah
yeah i've
seen a lot of porns like that uh
elodie what uh how did you how are you
named elodie where does that come from
um it's just like a typical french name
so like
i don't know it's like
people tend to like get very confused
because like you're asian so why do you
have like this french name like i don't
know yeah tell me about it
my name is homs
first
i was like are his parents like from
germany because like mine are from
france and so i was like i wasn't sure
if like i don't know
uh no my parents are not nazis uh
they came over during the korean war
uh no uh my parents made me hans because
they didn't want kids at school to make
fun of me for having an asian name
so you don't have a korean name i do yes
what is it uh my korean name is kim hang
and now you guys
he's laughing at my name
it's a wedja it's uh it's only two
syllables usually korean names are three
syllables so a lot of people think i
have a small dick is
what it boils down to
why what made you laugh at my beautiful
korean name
i'm korean i get a pass to laugh at you
okay yeah koreans are very spiteful
very uh snide no i'm just kidding love
korea you must be north korean you
you're you're very mean
um
uh so kia so what uh where where have
you been mostly dating on campus at ut
or
do i look that young yeah you look young
as [ __ ] grad student that's like what i
thought
uh i'm a working professional okay um no
so i actually i'm here with my partner
we met on bumble during the uh pandemic
who gave me who cove at first
we
we're very confused because neither of
us have had covet oh okay
that's usually not what people are
confused about i thought you were going
to say you're like bi or something
is that your girlfriend right there
the white woman uh no i can't i was like
really hard to see will you raise your
hand or are you two
oh my god
you're on a date with another asian
woman
are we that replaceable to you dude no
oh she thinks she's better than us
[ __ ] chinese
you met a chinese woman on bumble dude i
did yeah wow very lucky that i did
uh as they call it bumbler
okay
god damn it if i can't make that joke
who can
so you met her on bumble you're two
young working professionals
more or less
okay is she in school
no i'm just not that young okay how old
are you
i'm
29 i'm 30 in a couple months that's
really scary
this guy's got jeff goldblum disease
i thought you were 23.
i'm gonna take that as a compliment
thank you
yeah your hair looks like you just woke
up from uh being 22.
do they let you go into the office with
hair like that
i don't have to go into the office whoa
you're
upper management no i just i work in a
company that's in california and
it's a very privileged software engineer
like uh you know okay
don't brag about no trust me it's not
you there's like a psychic weight to it
i don't know if you feel the same way oh
you you haven't started no guilt okay no
guilt
she has no guilt she's a heartless
korean mom already
uh where do you work do you work from
home also uh no so i'm still in school
right now but i do like do work outside
of school just not related to my field
yet okay no one's accusing you of being
lazy koreans
koreans always have to let you know
goodness i'm like getting asked a
question by another asian adult and i
immediately was like i can't sound like
a neat right now
yeah you don't want to just be going to
school like a loser
asians are crazy as [ __ ] man
you can't just be going to school uh
what are you doing in school uh so i'm
studying computer science right now i
also want to go into software
engineering because i want a job that's
like nice while you're talking to a real
live computer right now
this guy's got all the information
what the
what's what's your dating history like
ooh it's a little messy
like basically like for some reason what
i've been doing is like every single
time i date a guy and there's something
i really don't like about him i end up
dating the exact opposite of that person
but then that just ends up like being
the extreme of like what i don't want
and it goes like back and forth so i
went from dating
black white black
that kind of happened
okay i mean it's 20 22.
uh what's uh how many uh like have you
done the un yet one from every continent
um not yet okay antarctica is hard
uh
so like uh have you ever dated koreans
i have
and
so
okay basically like what my friends and
i have concluded is we're kind of like
koreans have like a little too much
pride for our taste and so we've kind of
just you want someone you can tear down
over time
she's a tiger mom a little power over
sure
yeah i mean she's so good at violin she
deserves it
do you play violin or concert master pro
violet concert master for violin
shot in the dark
i don't know how i knew that you played
violin i do not play violin i'm a
comedian i am not a good korean
i got a 2.6 gpa
in college
uh but uh yeah kia so uh what does your
girlfriend think about your name is she
like
does she have a kia
she does not i don't know if i've ever
asked her what she thinks about my name
when you pull this profile up on bumble
did you think it was a commercial for
ikea
oh
kia
you a fan of kia
this the human being
oh [ __ ] a lot of hesitation there yeah
that's like basically an asian woman
saying i love you
uh but yeah that's cool you're you're
dating fan um
what's your last name kia
i don't know if i want to dox myself on
this stage right now
yeah everyone wants to doxx you dude
everyone wants to find you we're very
you're very sexy man i'm sure someone's
gonna thank you i want to find you
uh but yeah
is that
is it like a weird combination like is
your name kia volkswagen or something
no
no my my last name is so the the white
way to pronounce it which i will be
honest i pronounce it is shaggy
khashoggi
ayatollah khomeini
yikes fan yeah you might want to keep
your lights there we've discussed it i
think she's going to keep it then
yeah it sounds like sarahan sirhan
welcome
a little bit
what an interesting couple
what do you think
what about kia
he looks like a little kid that grew up
a little bit
i think technically everyone in here is
a little kid yeah
that was really deep of you thank you
i'm a professional
you look like you do really well at
sleepovers you get invited to a lot of
sleepovers
i'm actually um really introverted and
so did not go to a lot of sleepovers
like that
being away from my own bed for a night
in my own home is very challenging for
me yeah you like patterns and rituals
hell yeah dude
yeah
i think i heard about this on the movie
rain man
uh but that's cool uh do you uh do you
have any rituals or uh you your ocd at
all
oh me yeah
um
so
i don't i don't think i have like
anything that's like any more out of the
normal than everybody else you're pretty
normally crazy i'm trying psychopathic
okay there's like certain things that
will kind of make me mad if they don't
go my way and if not organized a certain
way but i don't think it's like ocd like
if you get a b
i'm a very average student that doesn't
bother me
nice american
american korean american first
yeah the shitty version of something
that's authentically asian
yes
one of my hilarious jokes
you want to hear it
well check it out on youtube
what's gonna say oh no hans don't do
your joke
yeah that's what most people say when i
get on stage
oh no
some guy is dying over there
he's my number one hater on youtube
thank you for coming sir
he's just here to
bash me
um but uh yeah i mean i think this is a
wonderful couple i think it's uh you
know kia brought his girl friend or
whatever he brought his fan
uh number one fan is here number one fan
what's the most funny fan joke you've
heard fan death or
yeah
she she did sign up so y'all could pick
her next
oh yeah you're definitely there's only
like oh there's three more four more
three more
uh yeah you know luck of the draw let's
hope it
fans out
set of pans out
uh yeah what do you think any any
parting words
britney me yeah
um
you kind of look like this guy what
movie was it it was a disney movie i
looked it up you look like the scarecrow
from batman begins oh no
cillian murphy
that's a sexy guy dude
okay thanks i wasn't i it's been a long
time so i wasn't sure
i got you bro
talking you up um
elite looks like the next hillary
clinton of asia
it's gonna be like our next chairman mao
tell ask fan to tell you about it
she's looking up uh cartoon movies to
see what you look like okay you look
like a cartoon dude you do look like a
cartoon dude
you look like a like a happy little boy
oh you look like the guy from treasure
planet is that it
oh the main character yeah can i see
no you don't look like well no never
mind i pulled it up it's from my fake
memory of it but then okay yeah yeah
you're not this rugged no offense
this cartoon is way hotter than me i'll
probably yeah he's probably not a
software engineer
yeah
it's made by a software engineer it's
making me kind of go software you know
what i mean uh no i uh loved your date
thank you guys for coming on we're gonna
get through another date but uh yeah
give it up for kia and elodie
going on a date
in front of his
girlfriend a lot of that going around
today
we got a couple more names left
three more women
we got giuseppa
giuseppa going on a date with cameron my
number one hater
on reddit
he's got the man bun and everything
the beard the full in-cell uniform
looks like amanda's
amanda's grabbing her purse
dulce sitting in the front row give it
up for giuseppe and
the guy who hates me
come was the same
cameron cameron
all right give it up for cameron and
giuseppa
hello
hi cameron hey so uh do you go down for
your pleasure
huh
nothing
uh
i'll rephrase do you like sucking dick
because you like sucking dick or you
just do it because thank you
oh no i'm sorry sorry
i'm very blunt sorry
you're what great blunts
blunt
i would like one too please
ah
[Music]
what's your favorite color i hate that
one that's next one sweep um
what do you do for a living
i'm a nanny
hey what do you do
engineer engineer what kind
i work in the semiconductor field robot
time give it up for the robotics man
connor hold it in cell uniform and just
separate
he's not an insult he's got special
needs
that no one will ever mean thank you
do you go down for your pleasure or what
we'll get down for your pleasure you
would ask that on a real date
oh my god it wouldn't be slapped i'm
pretty sure
at least shave your man bun off before
you ask that question you can't do both
uh
my manscapes as well as he landscapes
his face ew
dude you look like a bad guy in every
pirate movie
you came with a beautiful lady is this
your date or your caretaker
no that's his nanny that's your nanny
how do i get a nanny no one's that one
that's a nanny nowadays
uh but yes you did ask a kind of a blunt
question up top
what uh what what are some others that
you had lined up in the chamber
uh
yeah what were you thinking of asking
that was it no that's a good question
they're finally saying smart [ __ ] right
now
um
yeah he's like i could do way better
than you and then he pulled the coaster
on this date and just bombs his ass off
uh connor um
yeah i mean
i really don't know what to say
that was preposterous we got it all on
video by the way it's on you're gonna be
reporting this to the authorities soon
no just kidding preposterous
i just like to keep it real connor
connor's keeping it real hey i go down
for my pleasure you look coming down
something about yourself
can you do a little courtesy with
consent though maybe pretend you have a
little trifold hat on just [ __ ] do
one of these there we go yes fedora
you role play but it's the three
musketeers
they role play but it's the renaissance
festival they could not run fair
hey we'd be down
who is we
that's your girlfriend i don't know if
y'all on reddit or not
no i'm a girl i know you're on reddit no
i'm pretty
you have it in your contacts right now
it's just like the hot links or whatever
you know just like you pull up reddit
it's like right there
first you ask if she likes to go down
for her pleasure then you bring up
reddit this date is not going very well
again i said instill uniform
uh looking for a third
looking verb
so what what about hot links on reddit
that's where it's at you know
say more where to find the third are you
telling us where you watch your porn
unicorn
unicorns are you like a furry
unicorn wants like a
yeah
what's going on see what's happening
who who you must make a lot of money
you work in semiconductors
what do you do there what
what are you semi-conducting because i
know it's not sexual tension
when people said embrace your sexuality
they did not mean this
this is too far this is a surprise don't
ruin that you're an adorable guy you uh
you love to go down on women what a what
a selfless gentleman well it sounds like
it's for his pleasure
so in a way selfish okay
anyways
giuseppe what is the weirdest second
weirdest thing that you've ever heard on
a date
uh heard or done
oh the weirdest thing you've done
i want to reveal nothing about myself to
you
more clothes please
defensive dating with giuseppe
connor would you like to answer that
question
well are we still on the same question
yeah yeah same question
um
on top of sonic
on top of sonic you had sex on top of
sonic the hedgehog did you work outside
were there roller skates
before or before
well
i was on roller skates i wasn't good
enough i can't believe you've had sex
congratulations
good for you man
how old are you
uh i'm the dirty thirty
you're 30 years old
yeah dude that's good fancy dirt sex
what by your 30 with a man bun like that
that's you're killing it you're
you're you're hitting a birdie his
tongue out i don't know if y'all saw
that
surely you know did you go down on her
prank
[Laughter]
he was like don't do it don't do it it
is undercover boss
it was actually dean stanfield in drag
uh inside joke
uh
connor so uh did you go down on this
girl on top of sonic
eat her slurping
unfortunately
it wasn't
it was self-serve night
um so you had sex on top of sonic were
you working at that sonic
you were an employee you were employed
out of sonic that you had sex it looks
like he was employed at sonic still
you're still wearing the uniform
it's giving arby
yeah do you like the meats and he likes
my roast beef they look like sonic's rip
off of the grimace
so that's cool you had sex on top of
sonic was it a co-worker or a customer
wait
wait how did that happen
it was like okay so she really likes the
mozzarella sticks
it's a sunday night
after work on sunday night you know we'd
all just gather on the patio and you
know
do our thing
uh you know smoke weed technology advice
there was a ladder that was blocked you
know but that was like secret location i
guess
how did you meet the customer
she liked that uh chili cheese coney no
like for real like how did you meet the
cousin i want to know how you could you
know hey uh so uh it was one of the
reddit links
what are you
what is the chili cheese coney
you haven't been to sonic
no i have not and i probably won't after
this neither will my sister's or my
girlfriend i'll show you it backstage
i'm like the vip it will be for his
pleasure
connor you're having a blast i'm glad
that uh you got a chance to date because
i don't know how many more of these you
have a third
well he's with a woman they're trying to
i know you guys are dating right
holy [ __ ] y'all are some freaks
welcome to what sonic did you meet at
expect it
oh
he just started this job too
where do you works you were to use uh
don't tell us where you work you're
gonna get fired for sure
so what do you do you make chips you
code
uh no so um
my company they have the patent that
makes the robots for all the companies
that make computer chips so
um
i just test robots but everybody buys
our [ __ ] okay next robots
section you test your robots test them
yeah you're really good at your job i
can tell
you're almost becoming a robot
um no but uh yeah you must be really
good at your job no there's no way
you're not
uh giuseppa what do you think this guy
makes a lot of money
no thank you
how did you meet your wife
hey try to thread right through
on one of the hotlicks texas roadhouse
texas road
like at the bar
no she was honest she a customer
did y'all have sex on the roof
texas ruth house
can you pretend like giuseppe is your
wife and you're saddling up next to
earth and uh let's go let's see what
let's see how you did it let's see you
work your magic in a not creepy way what
oh
he wore you down took some convincing
what did you say what does the pretend
joseph uh like let's make believe you
know let's uh let's let's see what you
said the straw that broke the camel's
back
uh
like uh verbally or like yes please
don't do anything physically
please only use your words do not
consent to you touching me
i said i said hey this [ __ ]
it ain't gonna work no don't [ __ ] with
me don't talk to me this [ __ ] ain't
gonna work you're all you are a bad boy
you're a really hurt
to
get hurt and it worked yeah
that's mentally ill
that's ill as [ __ ] dude give it up for
it turn into it
yeah like this [ __ ] ain't gonna work see
ya
hey uh
i
the hand gesture
i love manipulating
we all appreciate the love story we all
appreciate what you're doing for the
society
um sliding does work
look at him he got laid
you're doing great dude i'm glad that uh
you know you're off the market you're
safely contained
i'm glad you're off the market
give it up for
cameron and just
no one got hurt in the making of this
date
so far
we're keeping a close eye on him
um
let's hope nothing bad happens in the
stairwell but that was a show yeah
thank you for coming thank you for
having me uh any any last thoughts any
what what uh what date do you think was
the best or uh i absolutely cherished
what just happened here
i give it up for a camera one more time
that was incredible thank you for having
me
thank you for being here give it up for
brittany ledesma
you can find her all over town
uh my name is hans kim thank you guys so
much stick around for the next show good
night
i